the fast and furious franchise has
created some iconic heroes behind the
wheel
and mia is no exception from her early
childhood in a family of car lovers to
building a family of her own
here's mia toretto's entire fast and
furious timeline
explained cars have long been synonymous
with the name tereto
as evidenced by mia's childhood where
she grew up with a professional stock
car driver as a father
and at least one older brother who
inherited his father's love of going
fast
the torettos were a close-knit family
attending church together
and hosting barbecues for their
neighbors a tradition that mia and dom
would continue as adults even though mia
wasn't the main gear head of the toretto
siblings
she still learned her way around an
automobile
picking up the same advanced driving
skills shared by all of the toretos
when mia was a teenager her father was
killed in an accident during a stock car
race
and dominic was subsequently sent to
prison for attacking the driver who
caused his death
so while teenage mia occasionally
participated in petty heists alongside
dom and his girlfriend
letty seeing her brother go to prison
may have prompted her to be more
reluctant about
taking part in his illegal schemes going
forward
as adults dom and mia remained close
continuing to work together
at their father's shop however they
never talked about their brother jacob
indicating that a rift formed in their
family at some point
and even though dominion maintained a
tight bond mia wasn't willing to
participate in dom's increasingly
elaborate heists
by the time the fast and the furious
begins dom and his crew
which includes letty and a few of his
and mia's childhood friends
have a pretty slick operation stealing
dvd players from 18 wheelers at high
speeds on the highway
mia is loyal enough to not turn them in
or thwart their illegal activities
she also makes it clear to dom that she
doesn't approve
still mia is always a safe person for
dom guarding his secrets and remaining
fiercely protective of him
even if she wishes he'd settle down and
leave his life of crime behind
although mia has a strict rule about not
dating any of her brother's friends
she makes an exception for brian
o'connor when he starts hanging around
toretto's market and cafe
granted at the time he and dom aren't
yet close
and neither toretto's sibling realizes
that brian is actually an
undercover lapd officer sent to get to
the bottom of dom's operation
but by the time their bromance is in
full bloom so is brian and mia's romance
when mia discovers brian's true identity
she feels portrayed
talking about brian what is this ever
since the first time i met you i've been
undercover
but she agrees to help him for dom's
sake and they rescue a wounded member of
dom's crew
dom isn't so forgiving threatening brian
with a shotgun as brian attempts to
arrest him
and while mia attempts to defuse the
situation the two end up in a high speed
chase
leaving her behind after learning the
true identity of brian o'connor
and that dom has had to go on the run
mia decides to pack up and move away
starting a new life on her own although
brian tells her he's resigned from the
lapd
after letting dom go she refuses to give
him another chance
until she later warms up to him and they
get close again
although dom remains on the run he never
loses contact with his sister who keeps
him informed of significant developments
during his periodic check-ins this can
be a little risky
since the fbi keeps mia under
surveillance but it proves important
when mia gets word that dom's
ex-girlfriend letty
has apparently been killed in a car
accident based on what mia tells him
and what he finds out at the scene dom
embarks on a quest
to track down lety's killer of course
this puts him back in the orbit of brian
who's now working for the fbi after
tracking down letty's killer in mexico
and killing him brian is unable to
secure the pardon for dom
that ledy had hoped to earn and dom is
sentenced to 25 years to life
in prison but this time rather than
continuing to operate within the
confines of the law
brian decides to take justice into his
own hands
although she's kept her brother's
criminal activities at arm's length up
until that point
seeing her brother sentenced to spend
the rest of his life in prison
is apparently the last draw for mia and
the fourth film
ends with her driving alongside brian
behind dom's prison bus
the opening of fast five is the first
time we really get to see mia's driving
skills in action
and she proves she's every bit as
capable as her big brother by seamlessly
coordinating
her car's maneuvers with bryan's
flipping the bus
and allowing dom to escape running low
on cash at the beginning of fast five
mia and brian both embrace their new
lives of crime by participating in a
heist
to steal a number of cars off of a
moving train
once the heist gets underway dom shows
up to lead the mission
but upon realizing that the other
members of his crew are preparing to
double-cross them
he gives mia a chance to escape before
he and brian are forced to fight their
way out
realizing they've gotten wrapped up in
something much more complicated than
they thought
the trio decide to stage a daring heist
in order to steal 100 million dollars
from a rio druglord to pull this off
they recruit a crew of dom and brian's
past associates while also being pursued
by various law enforcement agents
including dss agent lou cobbs
you turn around and put your hands
behind your back after revealing that
she's pregnant with her and brian's
first child
mia explains that she wants her family
to stick together this time
however since none of them are willing
to risk mia's pregnancy
she opts to take a more administrative
role in the rio heist
rather than the hands-on one she had for
breaking dom out of prison
still mia's role is hardly safe while
planning the heist
the drug lord's men attempt to kidnap
her but she's able to narrowly escape
however pretty much the moment mia
escapes one dangerous situation
she's put in another one when she's
arrested by hobbs
along with brian and dom but when their
convoy is ambushed
brian and dom save the dss agent who
decides to join their heist plan
even though the drug lord now knows
they're coming the group goes ahead with
the mission
with mia coordinating their roots from
their home base while brian and dom
are in the thick of the action against
all odds the group successfully pulls it
off
and our heroes end fast five as
multi-millionaires
rich beyond their wildest dreams after
the events of fast five
fast and furious six finds brian and mia
retired in the canary islands
in welcoming the arrival of their first
child a boy
they named jack however despite their
idyllic surroundings
brian tells dom that it still doesn't
quite feel like home to him
however he isn't anxious to leave when
don tells him that he's been informed by
hobbes that letty
is actually still alive in fact brian
initially tries to talk him out of going
to find her
however mia won't hear of such a thing
reminding the two most important men in
her life that they're all family
she'd feel more comfortable and safe
knowing they were watching
each other's backs you're stronger
together mia remains at home with jack
while brian and dom go to reunite their
former crew in their mission to rescue
letty
plus they also plan on bringing down the
terrorist owen shaw
in exchange for pardons which will allow
them all to return to the united states
little do dom and brian realize that
while they're pursuing shaw in spain
the bad guy has sent his goons to
brian's house to kidnap mia
as a contingency plan so when dom's crew
manages to win back lety and capture
shaw
he plays the card they didn't know he
was holding threatening to kill mia
unless they let him go free although it
means giving up their chances at earning
their pardons
no one on dom's crew hesitates to give
in to shaw's demands
allowing him to leave with some
weaponized technology that he's stolen
fortunately before mia was kidnapped she
had the presence of mind to hand off
baby jack to dom's girlfriend
former police officer elena who manages
to escape
safely with the baby and when the
villains bring mia with them
to shaw's plane dom and his crew follow
them and work together to prevent it
from taking off
dom and brian drive a car onto the plane
which mia uses
as a distraction in order to get away
from her captors
reuniting with brian the two are able to
escape the plane and work together to
help take down shaw in exchange for
recovering the stolen technology
dom negotiates pardons for them all as
well as getting back his
and mia's childhood home in los angeles
by the time little jack is in preschool
at the beginning of furious 7
brian and mia are still living in their
old home and trying to adjust to
domestic life
however despite their minivan and
peaceful routine
mia knows brian misses the thrills and
excitement of his former life
mia worries that he won't ever be able
to fully settle into a quiet life with
their family
and she confesses to dom that she's
pregnant with their second child
she hasn't told brian though because she
worries that in deciding to stay with
her
and raise a family he'll be disappointed
in his life
just as he is done consoling his sister
dom receives a phone call from owen
shaw's brother
deckard played by jason statham and
realizes there's a bomb at the house
dom's warning gives brian just enough
time to protect little jack
but the home where brian anemia live the
same one where the toreto siblings grew
up
is completely destroyed with their home
gone
and deckard shaw coming for their family
mia and jack go to stay with a friend
in the dominican republic however
knowing they won't be safe while shaw is
still out there
mia urges brian to go with dom to help
him stop shaw and keep their family safe
against dom's urging she still doesn't
tell brian about her pregnancy
but later when brian calls mia from los
angeles to tell her that they're about
to attempt a mission so dangerous
that he wants her to move on if she
doesn't hear from him again
she finally tells him about the
pregnancy and that they're expecting a
girl
nia refuses to accept his goodbye after
defeating deckard shaw once and for all
dom and brian and the rest of the crew
head to the beach along with mia and
little jack
while the gang looks at brian and mia
playing in the surf with jack
they all acknowledge that brian belongs
with his family not pulling heists with
them
and as brian and mia anticipate the
birth of their daughter
they lovingly part ways with their fast
and furious lifestyle
as well as the crew that feels as close
as family
of course off screen the reason for
brian and mia's pond farewell from the
fast crew was due to actor paul walker's
tragic death
during the filming of furious 7 which
prompted a rewrite of the ending
in order to give brian a happy and
satisfying send-off
since mia has always been an
inextricable part of brian's story
as both his partner in crime and love
there was really no way to offer brian a
happy ending without sending mia off
into the sunset by his side
after sitting out the eighth installment
of the fast saga
living happily in retirement with brian
and their two children
mia returns to the more furious side of
the fast fold
in f9 which will finally introduce jacob
played by john cena the previously
unmentioned third turretto sibling
perhaps the family tie is what draws mia
back in for another adventure
or maybe she has other reasons for
rejoining the crew
for one last ride it will be interesting
to find out how
f9 justifies nia being the one to take
part in the action
while brian stays home with the kids
when in the past
those roles have been reversed but maybe
it will be as simple as the fact that
mia is a toretto and the only thing for
torettos that rivals their love of
family
is their desire to keep moving fast and
furious
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite film franchises are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]